erste ergebnisse im fall navalny ärzte
der charité finden hinweise dass der
kremlkritiker vergiftet wurde
streit über corona maßnahmen länder
debattieren über einheitliche regeln bei
bußgeldern und masten pflicht und großer
triumph bescheidene rückkehr der
champions league sieger muss corona
bedingt auf die große feier verzichten
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und
willkommen zum nachrichtenüberblick an
diesem montag norbert lehmann ist auch
dabei natürlich mit dem sensationellen
bringen tja dann lass uns doch mal das
goldene tor von gestern abend anschauen
59 spielminute münchen stürmer kingsley
koman trifft zum 1 0 endstand übrigens
das 500 tor der bayern in der champions
league also im doppelten sinn ein ganz
besonderer treffer dazu später mehr
zunächst zum politthriller um alex sei
seit samstag ist der prominente
russische oppositionelle in der berliner
charité
heute gab es den ersten schriftlichen
befund im gegensatz zu ihren russischen
kollegen gehen die deutschen ärzte davon
aus dass navalny vergiftet wurde
die kanzlerin reagierte prompt sie
fordert die verantwortlichen zur
rechenschaft zu ziehen
der 44-jährige navalny wäre nicht der
erste kremlkritiker der opfer eines
giftanschlags wurde am unesco anspannung
heute rund um die berliner charité
alles wartet auf eine nachricht der
mediziner am nachmittag dann wird eine
pressemitteilung verschickt demnach
deuten die untersuchungen auf eine
vergiftung navalny es hin
die klinischen befunde weisen auf eine
intoxikation durch eine substanz aus der
wirkstoffgruppe der cholinesterase
hemmer in die konkrete substanz ist
bislang nicht bekannt und es wurde eine
weitere breit gefächerte analytik
initiiert gesundheitszustand des
russischen oppositionspolitiker sei
weiterhin ernst heißt es aus der klinik
akute lebensgefahr bestehe derzeit aber
nicht navalny als ein gegenmittel
experten ist die gefundene wirkstoff
gruppe durchaus geläufig aus
pflanzenschutzmitteln oder kampfstoffen
collien ist der ac turin ist ein
botenstoff im nervensystem und damit
greift das nervensystem an zuerst merkt
man speichelfluss dann wird das herz
langsam dann werden irgendwann die
muskeln schwach und irgendwann ist das
auch wenn es nicht behandelt wird
tödlich noch in unkenntnis der neuen
lage äußerte sich die bundesregierung am
vormittag aber einen flug nach
deutschland sei aufgrund einer konkreten
anfrage erfolgt die bundeskanzlerin hat
wie auch der französische präsident in
ihrer ersten reaktion gesagt wenn es den
wunsch der familie gibt dann wird
deutschland bereitstehen um die
notwendige medizinische versorgung
dieses mannes auf den mutmaßlich ein
gift anschlag verübt worden ist sicher
zu stellen
navalny der frau äußerte sich heute
nicht täglich besucht sie ihren mann im
krankenhaus aus moskau und berlin sind
unsere korrespondenten zugeschaltet saß
nach berlin zur theo koll
die kanzlerin hat sehr schnell auf den
befund reagiert ja und nicht nur die
kanzlerin sollen kanzlerin und
außenminister gemeinsam heiko maas wurde
sogar eigens im flugzeug auf der
rückreise aus kiew einbezogen eine
solche gemeinsame erklärung ist
diplomatisch eher selten und sie ist
zudem unmissverständlich formuliert ich
zitiere einmal die zentralen sätze
angesichts der herausgehobenen rolle von
herrn navalny in der politischen
opposition sind die dortigen behörden
dringlich aufgerufen diese tat bis ins
letzte aufzuklären und das in voller
transparenz und die verantwortlichen
müssen ermittelt und zur rechenschaft
gezogen werden zitat ende
das ist nicht nur sehr deutlich sondern
durch die doppelte unterschrift dürfte
es in moskau auch genauso gelesen werden
wie es gemeint ist als politisch gelbe
latif gelbe karte aus berlin
dazu kann uns mehr für begann sagen die
aus moskau zugeschaltet ist für welche
reaktionen gibt es in russland aus der
russischen politik gibt es bisher noch
gar keine reaktionen und wenn man sich
ähnliche fälle aus der vergangenheit
anschaut dann muss man wohl davon
ausgehen dass es auch noch eine weile so
bleibt denn sowohl bei dem sogenannten
tiergarten mord wo ja die der deutsche
general bundesanwalt in richtung
staatlicher russischer stellen ermittelt
als auch im fall des hacker angriffs auf
den deutschen bundestag
heißt es aus moskau eigentlich immer
legt uns doch erstmal beweise vor und
wenn die deutschen ermittlungsbehörden
dann mit beweisen und argumenten kommen
blatt moskau dennoch bei dieser
abwehrenden haltung
die pressesprecherin von alexei navalny
hat kurz nach der veröffentlichung der
charité getwittert sie sei schon von
anfang an davon ausgegangen dass alexej
nawalny vergiftet wurde das habe schon
die besatzung des krankenwagens auf dem
weg in die klinik nach omsk ihr so
mitgeteilt jetzt hoffen sie darauf dass
das russische ermittlungskomitee tätig
werde
aber auch da wenn man sich die fälle von
vergifteten oppositionspolitikern oder
auch kreml kritischen journalistin aus
der vergangenheit anschaut dann muss man
davon ausgehen dass auch diese hoffnung
ins leere läuft denn die ermittlungen
liefen eigentlich wenn sie denn
aufgenommen wurden ins leere die
hintermänner dieser taten wurden
eigentlich nie vor gericht gestellt
danke für diese einschätzung nur und
berlin
und jetzt zur lage in belarus dort
versucht präsident lukaschenko immer
martialischer die massenproteste gegen
ihn zu stoppen
so präsentierte er sich gestern drohend
mit kalaschnikow in der hand während
zeitgleich mehr als hunderttausend
menschen auf den straßen seinen rückzug
fordern auch heute organisierte die
opposition wieder protestaktionen für
begann berichtet verhaftung am mittag in
minsk zwei führende köpfe der villa
russischen opposition werden abgeführt
wegen der untergrabung der nationalen
sicherheit wird gegen sie ermittelt
weitere mitglieder des oppositionellen
koordinationsrats werden vorgeladen
der rat tritt für einen friedlichen
macht das fan bus ein und hatte gestern
zur kundgebung aufgerufen
die straßen der hauptstadt erfüllt vom
wunsch nach einem demokratischen
neuanfang einer zukunft ohne präsident
lukas schenkel mit kalaschnikow und
schusssicherer weste bedankte er sich
bei den spezialkräften rief ihnen zu wir
werden mit denen fertig muskelspiele von
denen viele belarussen sich nicht mehr
beeindrucken lassen
meiner meinung nach ist das sowohl
lustig als auch traurig für den
präsidenten des landes ist ein solches
verhalten inakzeptabel
er ist ein guter schauspieler
er ist in einer art szene in einer rolle
aus der er alleine nicht rauskommt
[Musik]
meinungsfreiheit in belarus zu lassen
repressionen stoppen diese forderungen
unterstrich bundesaußenministers heute
bei seinem besuch in der ukraine
herr lukaschenko muss nach diesem
erneuten wochenende das wir erlebt haben
voller proteste die realität auf den
straßen seines landes anerkennen aber
auch die realität in den köpfen der
menschen in diesem land dass es noch
lange dauern könnte bis
langzeitherrscher lukaschenko sich auf
einen dialog mit der opposition ein
lässt darauf sind sie eingestellt in
belarus und deswegen sind sie auch heute
wieder auf die straße gegangen nach
deutschland zum kampf gegen korona da
fordern ministerpräsidenten zum beispiel
aus bayern und hamburg jetzt ein
einheitliches vorgehen der länder also
zum teil schärfere beschränkungen
das halten die weniger betroffenen
länder nicht für sinnvoll
doch der druck wächst angesichts
steigender infektionszahlen im schnitt
der vergangenen sieben tage haben sich
1360 menschen neu mit krone infiziert am
tag zuvor waren es 1 1340
dabei sieht die situation in deutschland
sehr unterschiedlich aus so liegt die
zahl der neuinfektionen in hessen in den
letzten sieben tagen bei 17,7 pro
100.000 einwohner in mecklenburg
vorpommern gerade mal bei 1,4
entsprechend unterschiedlich sehen die
bundesländer handlungsbedarf an seinem
stern berichtet
freude an der musik in hamburg live vor
ort und mit abstand zum ersten mal seit
fünf monaten durften wieder einige
hundert besucher zu einem konzert in die
elbphilharmonie normalität wohltuend
aber in manchen fällen auch riskant wie
groß dürfen veranstaltungen sein wie
groß kann privat gefeiert werden der
aktuelle maßnahmen flickenteppich in
deutschland für viele ein problem die
entwicklung bei krones besorgniserregend
wir müssen jetzt die zügel wieder
anziehen und sie nicht lockern
deswegen ist wichtig dass wir mehr
einheitlichkeit in deutschland bekommen
einheitlichkeit ist deshalb gut weil es
für bürgerinnen und bürger schwierig
genug ist diese verschiedenen regeln zu
verstehen
einheitlichkeit macht die sache
verständlicher dadurch wird die
einhaltung verbessert und dadurch wirken
die maßnahmen des parteiübergreifend der
appelle für klare bundesweite anti virus
regeln etwa beim thema strafen für
masken verweigerer oder besucher
obergrenzen bei feiern
aber diese appelle stoßen auf widerstand
keinen handlungsbedarf sieht man derzeit
zum beispiel in sachsen anhalt wir haben
sie unterschiedliche infektionszahlen in
deutschland und das rechtfertigt auch
dass man unterschiedliche festlegung in
den landesregierungen trifft auf der
anderen seite ist es so dass wir
sicherlich eine einheitlichkeit brauchen
wenn es um den urlaubsverkehr die
urlaubsrückkehrer geht da gilt aktuell
es wird kräftig getestet nach der
einreise etwa am flughafen
das aber könnte sich bald ändern mit dem
ende der reisewelle sollen tests hier
eingespart werden
wer dann noch reist in risikogebiete der
muss sich dann eben auch tatsächlich in
quarantäne begeben sofort quarantäne
statt dem schnellen corona abstrich es
ist einiges in bewegung in sachen virus
regeln
am donnerstag beraten die länderchefs
mit der kanzlerin
sie haben einiges zu klären einen
einheitlichen mindeststandards gibt es
auch für bußgelder nicht wer in sachsen
anhalt oder brandenburg keine maske
trägt muss keinerlei strafe befürchten
in hamburg drohen 40 euro bußgeld in
nordrhein westfalen 150 euro dort wird
ab heute die masken pflicht in
regionalzügen und s-bahnen strenger
kontrolliert alexander hettich über
erste erfahrungen masten kontrolle im
essener hauptbahnhof bundespolizisten
sprechen einen totalverweigerer an er
sieht keinen nutzen in den masken keine
gefahr durch corona das ist vorbei das
abgeklungen
ich weiß nicht warum man das hier so
krampfhaft versucht festzuhalten
diese diese vorgabe eine maske tragen zu
müssen die polizei schickte den mann
ohne maske vor die tür dort kann er
seine meinung weiter vertreten ohne
andere zu gefährden
kontrolleure überprüfen die massen
pflicht auch in der s-bahn richtung
düsseldorf die allermeisten hielten sich
dran sagen sie einen totalverweigerer
gab es auch hier kontaktieren wir die
kollegen von der bundespolizei und der
wird dann auch übergeben
nur wenn sich jemand komplett quer
stellt kassiert die polizei bußgeld 150
euro in nrw da wo man das gefühl hat er
jetzt darauf ankommen ist es auch
richtig dass man ein bußgeld gibt es ist
keine kleinigkeit
das ist das stück achtsamkeit und
solidarität miteinander die wir glaube
ich alle voneinander auch verlangen
können
die meisten masken wofür vision die
sicherheitskräfte in den bahnhöfen viele
fahrgäste haben verständnis für die
kontrollen gibt
sie halten sich halt viele nicht dran
allerdings für den gesundheitsschutz
bleibt entscheidend dass viele fahrgäste
freiwillig mitmachen
wir schauen in die usa zum wahlkampf die
demokraten haben ihre kandidatenkür
schon hinter sich jetzt sind die
republikaner dran
vor wenigen minuten haben sie wie
erwartet donald trump zum
präsidentschaftskandidaten nominiert der
parteitag in charlies fällt wegen der
korona krise allerdings deutlich kleiner
aus als sonst nur wenige teilnehmer
reisen persönlich an der höhepunkt soll
am donnerstag in washington sein
rampl seine rede vor dem weißen haus
halten seit gut einer woche ist ein
weiteres deutsches rettungsschiff auf
dem mittelmeer im einsatz die swatch
vier sie hat bereits etwa 200
flüchtlinge an bord genommen
die migranten waren aufgeboten vor der
libyschen küste entdeckt worden
die helfer hoffen auf einen sicheren
hafen in italien oder malta der kauf der
cbot 4 geht auf eine initiative der
evangelischen kirche zurück wenn einer
geht wird der platz für einen anderen
frei so war das auch im dax im deutschen
aktienindex als der skandal trächtige
bezahldienstleister wirecard rausflog
stattdessen gehört hat heute den livery
hero zum kreis der 30 größten
börsennotierten unternehmen dieser
internetkonzern organisiert
essenslieferungen nach hause und zwar
weltweit das geschäft in deutschland hat
allerdings verkauft markus deibler hat
details der live wie hero gegründet 2011
setzt auf schnelles wachstum
mittlerweile ist das unternehmen in 43
ländern aktiv in unterschiedlichen
tochterunternehmen gibt es 25.000
mitarbeiter und das ist das
geschäftsmodell der hypo ist bindeglied
zwischen hungrigen kunden und
restaurants die essensbestellung läuft
über online plattformen des unternehmens
fahrer der delivery töchter liefern geld
kommt rein weil die restaurants
monatliche gebühren bezahlen um auf der
plattform präsent zu sein und für jede
einzelne bestellung zusätzliche prämien
so kam die live view wo 2009 10 auf
einen umsatz von 1,24
euro gewinne gab es aber nicht
stattdessen ein - 648 millionen euro
valerie haller an der börse in frankfurt
warum landet so ein konzern im dax mit
daimler basf und vw obwohl er noch nicht
einen cent gewinn gemacht hat ja das
liegt an den regeln der börse sie schaut
nämlich vor allem auf den aktienhandel
wo steht der kurs der aktie
wie viele und wie stark werden die
papiere gehandelt und dann hatte livery
hero einfach die vorgaben erfüllt ob das
unternehmen gewinn abwirft spielt keine
große rolle auch nicht dass anbieter wie
delivery hero vielfach dafür kritisiert
werden ihren kurierfahrer hungerlöhne zu
bezahlen
die liffe hero ein krisengewinner
während der korona epidemie ist der
essence lieferant gefragt wie nie plus
35 prozent in nur sechs monaten damals
noch im mdax vertreten
lieferdienste gehören zum härtesten
online geschäft der welt damit geld zu
verdienen fällt selbst großen wie amazon
und über schwer heute erster tag im dax
der lieferdienste einzige verlierer in
der ersten börsenliga
der markt für die verdienste ist hart
umkämpft überleben können nur große
anbieter ob der avery hero dazu gehören
wird ist noch keine ausgemachte sache
danke nach frankfurt ganz anderes thema
jetzt ein urteil zugunsten der gießener
frauenärztin christina handle
das landgericht hamburg hat einem
radikalen abtreibungsgegner untersagt
sie mit ärzten in konzentrationslagern
der nazis zu vergleichen
außerdem darf der mann auf seiner
internetseite schwangerschafts abbrüche
nicht mehr mit dem holocaust in
verbindung bringen
nach dem verlorenen champions league
finale gegen bayern münchen haben in
paris einige randalierer ihrem frust
freien lauf gelassen
rund um das stadion von paris st germain
und auf den champs-élysées zündeten sie
autos an zerstörten schaufenster und
verwüsteten geschäfte die polizei
bewarfen sie mit flaschen und
feuerwerkskörper
die sicherheitskräfte reagierten mit
gas und gummigeschossen etwa 150
personen wurden festgenommen
die französischen spieler dagegen sehr
fair verlieren ist teil des sports
twitterte nehmer nach dem spiel schlecht
aber jetzt kommen wir zu den
glückstrunken in bayern gewinnen ist ja
auch der schönere teil des sports und
den konnten die münchner für sich
verbuchen
durch den knappen aber verdienten 1
0-sieg bayern kapitän manuel neuer mit
dem henkelpott zum sechsten mal gewinnt
der fc bieten wichtigste trophäe im
europäischen vereinsfußball ja und holt
zum zweiten mal das triple eigentlich
alles gründe für eine rauschende
siegesfeier heute mit den fans in
münchen
doch in zeiten von corona undenkbar und
deshalb gab es nur einen kurzen auftritt
der mannschaft am münchner flughafen die
rückkehr der helden von lissabon am
münchner flughafen fast unter ausschluss
der öffentlichkeit eine kurze corona
gerechte begrüßung durch bayerns
ministerpräsident markus söder
das war die grosse party gab es gestern
beim abendlichen bankett wo bayern boss
karl heinz rummenigge
nur lobende worte für diese sympathische
mannschaft findet und bin ja schon lange
in einem geschäft das größte spektakel
was ich jemals erleben durfte und ich
glaube wir haben eine mannschaft
ich habe es halt nur einen verschworenen
haufen erlebt als als diese truppe
wollte ich möchte danke sagen
nicht nur beim 100 zeigt sich das
perfekte harmonische zusammenspiel
dieser elf bei der jeder für den anderen
einsteht und niemand seinen ego trip
auslebt echter teamgeist eben der sich
auszahlt es ist gar nicht so wirklich zu
beschreiben was man empfindet mit seiner
truppe auf dem platz zu stehen wenn man
ja wirklich mit mitbrüdern titel gewinnt
dann ist das das maximum was man
erreichen kann
erstmals hat eine mannschaft alle spiele
auf dem weg zum final sieg gewonnen in
dieser verfassung wird der fc bayern
seinen fans noch viel freude bereiten
können
vielleicht ja auch irgendwann mal wieder
vor vollen rängen im stadion
[Applaus]
sophia popov hat sensationell als erste
deutsche golf spielerin ein major
turnier gewonnen
die bis dahin nummer 304 der
weltrangliste siegte gestern abend bei
den british open im schottischen thron
schon vor dem letzten part fließen die
tränen erst auf den letzten drücker hat
sie sich überhaupt für dieses major
turnier qualifizieren können
ich habe in den letzten jahren so hart
dafür gearbeitet hatte so viele probleme
und es war ja nicht einmal absehbar dass
ich hier spielen kann bei diesem major
diese möglichkeit genutzt zu haben ist
unglaublich gut 570.000 euro preisgeld
ist pop ups triumph wert sie verbessert
sich in der weltrangliste um 280 plätze
auf rang 24
was für eine unglaubliche geschichte
absolut ich bin aber auch immer noch ein
bisschen bei kimmig der sagte mitbrüdern
titel gewinnen das ist teamgeist ist so
schön aber ich habe auch noch eine
erfolgsgeschichte und einen ansporn für
schatzsucher in israel haben zwei
jugendliche bei einer organisierten
grabung einen goldschatz gefunden
vor 1100 jahren sollen sie in der erde
versteckt worden seien insgesamt 425
münzen aus dem reich der avancierten
auch damals gab es übrigens schon
kleingeld dazu wurden die münzen einfach
verteilt
der hochsommer wird zusehends zum
spätsommer oder gar zum herbst es wird
nämlich kühler und der wind nimmt zu die
details hat gleich katja horneffer was
der sieg der bayern wirtschaftlich
bedeutet klären die kollegen von wiso
gleich im anschluss und wir sehen uns
morgen wieder wenn sie mögen machen sie
sich noch einen schönen abend
danke für ihr interesse auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
den abend meine damen und herren vom
hochsommer rutschen die jetzt fast schon
in den frühherbst enden über dem
atlantik braut sich das erste stürmische
tief zusammen das ist das sturmtief
kirsten das bringt morgen schon
großbritannien viel regen und auch wind
und am mittwoch dann auch uns heute
nacht ist es meist noch ruhig nur an den
küsten von nord- und ostsee zu
regenschauer und gewitter wie auch in
den westlichen mittelgebirgen
sonst wird das eine sehr frische nacht
und die temperaturen sinken nämlich auf
13 grad in der lausitz bis 9 grad im
vogtland
morgen erwarten uns dann höchst
temperaturen um 20 grad milder wird es
zum beispiel hier in der lausitz oder
auch am oberrhein mit 24 oder 26 grad
kühler bleibt es an den küsten bei 18
oder 19 grad
und dazu ist auch klar von welcher seite
die regenwolken kommen nämlich von
nordwesten und die erreichen bis zum
abend den niederrhein die bühne
burgerheide und die ostsee unlängst ein
freundlich bleibt das südwestlich der
donau dann kommt der mittwoch und das
sturmtief kirsten das merken sie vor
allen dingen in norddeutschland das sind
durchaus windgeschwindigkeiten von 60 70
80 kilometer pro stunde möglich sonst
aber geht es doch ruhig und wechselhaft
weiter und noch bleibt es nicht schön
aber noch